the differences between cyberpunk 2077
on release and the 2.0 patch are even
bigger than I realized check this out
here's what happened when you shot tires
when the game first came out
nothing and here's what happens in patch
2.0
we can shoot tires now here's what it
used to look like if you'd spin your
tires while driving
here's what it looks like now this one
is jumping out of your car
kind of nothing happened it's very
strange he isn't a 2.0 update
makes a lot more sense they've also
massively improved water details this is
before looks kind of crappy character
stays on the bike for some reason this
is in the 2.0 update water has way more
texture it's more reflective and as you
naturally should you actually come off
the bike and start swimming of course
loads of other stuff has changed now too
the cops react differently and much more
appropriately NPCs will react to you
differently it's just like across the
board a huge Improvement to the base
game